se han preguntado alguna vez por qué los
perros no organizan eventos como este
porque no hacen charlas ted
algunos de ustedes me dirían bueno pues
porque los perros no hablamos
y aunque sí que tienen un lenguaje
propio ciertamente no es tan sofisticado
como el nuestro para transmitir ideas
pero supongamos por un segundo que el
lenguaje perro no es suficientemente
sofisticado como para transmitir ideas
de interés para otros perros
algún otro de ustedes me diría bueno lo
que pasa es que a los perros no le
interesan este tipo de eventos porque va
a cada uno a su rollo
y eso también es cierto generalmente los
perros no muestran interés por compartir
sus vivencias con otros individuos más
allá de juguetear con los que sienten
afinidad o mostrar hostilidad hacia los
que les resultan amenazantes
pero supongamos por un segundo que si
existiese ese tipo de interés
podrían aún así un grupo de perros
sentarse tranquilamente en un recinto
durante 10-15 minutos para escuchar los
ladridos de otro perro
ciertamente el lenguaje el interés por
compartir ideas y la cooperación son
habilidades en las que el ser humano es
bastante bueno y tiene mucho que ver con
el hecho de que organicemos este tipo de
eventos
pero existe una capacidad mucho más
básica sin la cual no sería posible la
inteligencia humana ni sería posible
organizar charlas ted
me refiero a la capacidad para gestionar
la atención de acuerdo a nuestras
intenciones
a través de la gestión de su atención
ustedes pueden regular su comportamiento
para escuchar y comprender lo que yo les
cuento
tener claras las intenciones y estar
motivado es muy importante para
gestionar la atención y en eso también
los seres humanos somos mucho más
complejos que otras especies porque
nuestras intenciones no son siempre
inmediatas como para un perro puede ser
obtener una caricia en el lomo o un poco
de comida sino que pueden ser más
abstractas como compartir una idea o más
a largo plazo e incluso probabilística
aprender algo que tal vez me pueda
servir para el futuro
así que la regulación de la atención y
del comportamiento en realidad es una
habilidad más compleja de lo que puede
parecer a simple vista
pero qué es la atención
para explicarlo de una forma sencilla
voy a hacer un símil entre el cuerpo y
la mente
nuestro cuerpo tiene únicamente dos
brazos con una mano al final de cada uno
de ellos y esto nos permite [ __ ] un
número limitado de cosas a la vez y la
propia forma física de nuestro cuerpo
nos limita en el número de objetos con
el que con los que podemos interactuar a
la vez
pues bien nuestra mente también tiene
limitado su espacio al menos el espacio
consciente
de forma que solamente podemos procesar
una cantidad limitada de información a
la vez y tomar un número limitado de
decisiones conscientes a la vez
así que la atención es quien regula la
entrada de información en el espacio
mental de trabajo un espacio de trabajo
en el que somos conscientes de la
información y tomamos decisiones en
función de nuestros objetivos
pues bien existen dos modos de control
de la atención por un lado la atención
puede ser controlada por los eventos que
ocurren en el entorno por ejemplo el
sonido de una alarma una bandada de
patos blancos un pato negro entre ellos
el que alguien pronuncia nuestro nombre
los eventos que son relevantes para
nosotros que son distintivos o novedosos
captan la atención de un modo automático
pero la atención también puede ser
controlada internamente por nuestras
propias intenciones de forma voluntaria
y con independencia de lo que ocurra en
el entorno a este segundo tipo de
atención le llamamos atención ejecutiva
porque su función es la de seleccionar
la información relevante y supervisar
que nuestras acciones y pensamientos
estén en sintonía con nuestro objetivo
este tipo de atención se requiere
especialmente cuando nuestra intención
es entran en conflicto con cosas que
hacemos habitualmente y de forma casi
automática un buen ejemplo sería cuando
estando acostumbrados a conducir por la
derecha viajamos a un país donde se
conduce por la izquierda en este caso
controlar la tarea la tarea de conducir
requiere tanto control atencional que
apenas quedan recursos para escuchar la
radio o conversar con la persona que
tenemos al lado
pues bien la atención automática es
claramente compartida con otras especies
muchos animales son mejores que nosotros
en sintonizar su atención hacia eventos
que ocurren en el entorno
las cosas que son distintivas y
relevantes para los perros cómo lanzar
una bola o la presencia de otro perro
captan su atención de forma automática
mi gato por ejemplo tiene su atención
perfectamente sintonizada con el sonido
de la puerta del armario donde guardo su
comida
sin embargo la atención ejecutiva es una
habilidad en la que el ser humano es
especialmente hábil en esta capacidad no
existe parangón en el reino animal es
realmente el ser humano es mejor que
ningún otro animal en la capacidad de
dirigir su atención voluntariamente
hacia lo que considera más importante
sin embargo el hecho de que seamos
buenos en esto no significa que no nos
cueste trabajo porque mantener la
atención focalizada bajo control es
realmente una labor bastante ardua y
consume un montón de recursos en
términos de energía cerebral
y esto es así porque la vida la
tendencia de la vida mental es a vagar
continuamente de una idea a otra así que
mantener la atención focalizada bajo
control es tan difícil cómo encausar el
agua
apenas exista una grieta en un canal el
agua se dispersaran por ella igual que
les sucede a nuestros pensamientos en el
espacio mental de trabajo
así que la labor de la atención es la de
encauzar la vida mental hacia la
consecución de nuestros objetivos y por
tanto es el sistema principal de
regulación de nuestro comportamiento el
canal de la atención es ciertamente
vulnerable a distintas condiciones por
ejemplo las emociones intensas tanto
positivas como negativas son uno de los
mayores causantes de grietas en el canal
de la atención sino piensen lo difícil
que le resultaría mantener su atención
en lo que les digo si de camino aquí se
hubieran enterado de que le ha tocado un
millón de euros en la lotería para
funcionar de forma óptima la atención
requiere de cierto nivel de activación
pero si la activación es demasiado baja
o demasiado alta mantener la atención
bajo control se complica enormemente
en condiciones como la hiperactividad
infantil el canal de la atención está
alterado de tal forma que para los niños
que sufren esta condición
y mantener la atención bajo control
sería tan difícil como tener que hacerlo
levantándose cada mañana con la noticia
de haber ganado la lotería
pues bien
esta capacidad de control atencional
está por supuesto relacionada con el
funcionamiento del cerebro
existen una serie de estructuras en el
cerebro que se ponen en marcha toda vez
que sintonizamos nuestra atención hacia
eventos que son relevantes para nuestras
intenciones
esta estructura que aparecen
representada en la figura que les
muestro conforman la red de atención en
el cerebro y tienen una estructura
principal un nodo principal en la región
anterior del giro simulado que hace esta
región que aparece pintada de rojo
esto lo sabemos porque desde hace varias
décadas contamos con la tecnología para
conocer lo que sucede en el cerebro de
los individuos en vivo mientras realizan
tareas que les pedimos pues bien a
continuación les voy a dar tres razones
por las tres razones que justifican el
título de mi charla es decir tres
razones por las que creer que la
atención es el corazón de la
inteligencia
la primera es que cuando los individuos
realizan tareas de las que se utilizan
normalmente para medir la inteligencia
se produce la activación de estas
estructuras de la red atencional en el
cerebro
la segunda es que en los individuos más
inteligentes estas partes del cerebro
elaboran y transmiten información de
forma más eficaz es decir están mejor
conectadas con otras partes del cerebro
e intercambian información por vía más
rápida
y la tercera es que cuando se compara el
cerebro humano con el cerebro de otras
especies de primates se observa que una
de las partes del cerebro que más ha
crecido a lo largo de la evolución es
precisamente la parte anterior del giro
cingulado es a ese nodo que aparecía
pintado de rojo anteriormente
de forma paralela desde el nacimiento
hasta la adultez esta parte del cerebro
también crece enormemente y su extensión
es mayor en individuos más inteligentes
pues todo esto nos indica que realmente
la capacidad para gestionar la atención
marca la diferencia en los individuos
más inteligentes
así que una pregunta muy pertinente que
sigue a esta argumentación es y podemos
mejorar el funcionamiento de la red de
atención al en el cerebro a través de
una intervención educativa es posible
entrenar la atención
esta pregunta parece bastante sencilla
pero en realidad tiene mucha
trascendencia porque durante mucho
tiempo muchos investigadores han
considerado que las capacidades
superiores del ser humano están
fundamentalmente determinadas por
factores biológicos como los genes y son
pocos susceptibles a la intervención
educativa
pues bien yo he trabajado en la
respuesta a estas preguntas desde hace
más de 15 años el interés por estas
cuestiones surgió durante mi etapa post
doctoral en eeuu a raíz de una
conversación con un colega que estaba
trabajando para un programa de la nasa
en el que debían de entrenar a monos con
tareas de atención este colega él le
contó a los profesores con los que yo
trabajaba en aquel momento que había
notado que los monos entrenados cuando
volvían al recinto que compartían con
otros monos eran más tranquilos más
regulados socialmente más sociables
aquello nos hizo pensar que sería una
buena idea entrenar la atención de los
niños y estudiar el impacto de ese
entrenamiento en el funcionamiento del
cerebro y en el comportamiento
pues bien ya han estado unidos y más
tarde en el laboratorio de neurociencia
cognitiva de la universidad de granada
donde dirijo a un equipo interesado por
el desarrollo de la atención y la
plasticidad cerebral hemos trabajado en
responder a estas preguntas
bien lo que hemos hecho es elaborar un
programa de entrenamiento que consiste
en una serie de ejercicios en los que es
necesario controlar la atención y
focalizar la atención a continuación les
voy a proponer un pequeño ejercicio de
los que usamos en el programa de
entrenamiento para que se hagan una idea
en este ejercicio lo que tienen que
hacer es decidir de forma ágil y
procurando no equivocarse cuál es el
animal de mayor tamaño real
venga
este sencillo ejercicio en realidad
tiene un truco habrán notado que en
algunas ocasiones el tamaño del dibujo
entra en conflicto con el tamaño real
del animal y esto hace que se requiera
un poquito más de control atencional
para darle la respuesta correcta
pues bien en nuestro estudio en el
laboratorio lo que hemos hecho es hacer
que los niños practiquen con este tipo
de ejercicios y muchos otros pero
basados en un principio similar y hemos
estudiado el efecto de la práctica con
estos ejercicios tienen sobre el
funcionamiento del cerebro y hemos
encontrado que después de practicar con
este programa de entrenamiento mejora el
funcionamiento de la red atencional en
el cerebro
también hemos demostrado que la práctica
continuada con este tipo de tareas que
incrementan en dificultad o
progresivamente también mejora la
inteligencia o al menos la ejecución de
los test de inteligencia tendría que
decir
en uno de los últimos estudios también
hemos mostrado que el efecto que tiene
el entrenamiento de la atención sobre el
funcionamiento del cerebro y sobre la
inteligencia es mayor cuando el
entrenamiento es guiado por un educador
todo esto nos indica que la atención y
el cerebro se pueden educar y que el
cerebro en cierto modo se parece a un
músculo cuyo funcionamiento será mejor
si lo entrenamos regularmente
además si entrenamos la capacidad de
regular la atención mejorará también el
control inteligente de nuestro
comportamiento
hoy en día nuestro diaria se ha llenado
de dispositivos y eventos que
continuamente demandan nuestra atención
tanto en la casa como en el trabajo como
en la calle estamos bombardeados por un
montón de información que compiten por
capturar nuestra atención
piensen que su atención es un recurso
muy codiciado en la sociedad actual
muchas webs ofrecen servicios que
supuestamente son gratis pero en
realidad lo hacen a cambio de tu
atención su negocio consiste en captar
su atención para vendérsela otros
la imagen que les pongo a continuación
muestra lo que sería tratar de leer el
periódico hoy hoy en día online donde
realmente hay que navegar entre un
montón de anuncios para poder encontrar
las noticias esto nos viene a decir que
gestionar la atención para dirigirla
hacia aquello que nosotros queremos
dirigirla voluntariamente
pues se ha convertido en un
en algo muy difícil pero a la vez muy
necesario
además el impacto que todos estos
distractores tienen sobre los niños es
mucho mayor ya que la capacidad para
regular la atención no está del todo
desarrollada hasta bien entrada a la
adolescencia
con frecuencia demandamos a los niños
localizarse en una idea en un evento o
en una actividad mientras están
bombardeados por un montón de otra
información
antes de comentado que para que la
atención funcione de forma óptima se
necesita cierto nivel de calma así que
por ejemplo apagar la televisión será un
buen recurso para poder focalizar la
atención en otra actividad como comer
leer o simplemente conversar
en nuestro laboratorio también hemos
demostrado que los niños con mejor
capacidad de regular su atención también
presentan un mejor rendimiento académico
son niños que son más capaces de regular
su comportamiento para alcanzar metas
futuras
además estos niños y niñas
son mejores controlando sus impulsos y
sus emociones por lo que su desarrollo
social y emocional es también mejor todo
esto indica que realmente la capacidad
para gestionar la atención es de una
importancia vital algunos estudios han
mostrado han hecho estudios
longitudinales en los que se ha
estudiado el desarrollo desde pequeños
hasta mayores de miles de personas y han
comprobado que la capacidad para
controlar el comportamiento durante la
niñez es uno es uno de los predictores
del éxito profesional y laboral así como
de índices de la salud en la en la edad
adulta
en definitiva la atención ejecutiva es
el sistema primordial de regulación del
comportamiento y el sistema de control
voluntario de nuestras acciones
es un sistema de crucial importancia
para la inteligencia y para el
aprendizaje
desde la psicología y la neurociencia es
nuestro deber educar a padres madres
maestros y maestras y a la sociedad en
general acerca de cómo funciona la
atención y cómo podemos educar la si
somos capaces de educar sistemáticamente
la atención de los niños en casas y
colegios
estaremos en camino de convertirles en
individuos más libres y con mejor
capacidad para desarrollar su enorme
potencial mental y emocional
muchísimas gracias por su estupenda
gestión de la religión